I think this is an appropriate moment to
try and
summarize some of the basic concepts
behind the course and actually very much
leading on from Prague miroslav and Doug
have just been saying and this this
starts with a a claim which is that to
understand the modern world you have to
be faith literate you have to understand
the role of faith and it is built on
what I'm going to call facts or certain
facts or certain I would say clear and
distinguishable elements of reality
about the modern world globalization is
is growing as a phenomenon and it is
driven by people and it is constantly
pushing the world together there is
nowhere I travel extensively there is
nowhere I go in the world today where it
is not obvious that the impact of
globalization is changing not merely the
economies but the societies of those
countries the other thing which until a
few years ago would have been a fact
that people would have questioned is
that faith is not diminishing it isn't
that grow that is not growing everywhere
and you could argue that in Europe and
some parts of the West it is diminishing
somewhat at least but it is nonetheless
growing worldwide and not simply within
the religion of Islam Christianity is a
growing phenomenon china for example
what what comes out of these these facts
are then other realities the interaction
between people is of a different nature
and as a result of globalization pushing
people together now what miroslav was
talking about where the encounter
between two is really between four
serenely between six which I was truffle
confused about to begin with but you've
got explained it and I understand
exactly what you mean actually it's very
important point because if you're with
somebody who's from the same village in
Europe the same faith in the same color
and the same ethnic background there are
a whole series of things that you assume
that you don't have to find out about
you just NAT it's very natural to you
you put in a whole lot of difference in
diversity that is then a different type
of encounter in a an account obviously
with with with more dimensions so that
interaction between people through
globalization through people of
interaction between people of different
faiths and cultures is qualitatively
really far more profound to understand
and to cope with than than in previous
times it is also correct that people's
faith can be as we set right at the
beginning it can be a source of identity
and is a source of identity for sure can
be a source of identity in opposition in
contradiction to others it can therefore
result in faith giving rise to conflict
which it doesn't we we saw the role of
religion is dominant in probably a
majority of conflicts now in in the
world but also faith can give rise to
good works that is plainly true as well
at the same time there are differences
between faiths and there are also as
Doug was just saying there is there is
some some point at which they
there seems to be a rapprochement of
values between the different phase we're
just dealing with facts now these are
the things that go to make up this sort
of the matrix of what I would call in
the matrix of realities around this
issue to do with faith and globalization
there are also this is another thing
that is happening in the world at the
moment there are debates within each
faith so one of the things that that is
really mistaken is to talk about a faith
as if there is a certain dominant view
within that faith of how it sees the
world actually you look at any major
faith today there is plainly a
traditional and a modernizing tendency
there is a reaching out tendency and a
reaching in tendency this this is true
with in virtual faith and if you take
debates over gender big debates over gay
rights you can do people in the same
faith reaching diametrically different
conclusions on these issues but faith
will be the prism within which many of
these issues are discussed and debated
here's something else that I think is
important is that faith communities
themselves are also evolving rather
involving often in different directions
and you can get even contradictory
directions but that is also happening so
my sort of starting point is you need to
be faith literate why because
globalization is growing pushing people
together the world of faith is growing
the interplay between people then
becomes more important faith can be a
force for good it can be a force for bad
there are clearly common areas within
between face there are major differences
but also there is this evolution within
the faith community where there are
differences between people as to what
they think even within the same faith
intra faith and the faith communities
them
cells are evolving so what this means in
my view and one of the things because
all the way through what I'm trying to
think of us one of the practical
consequences for for policy for thought
as a result of this what is obvious is
this relationship between the world of
faith in the world of globalization is
an important part of understanding the
modern world and having a relationship
that is positive between those two is an
important part of making the modern
world work now one of the practical
consequences out of this I think is that
we need to develop actually a far
greater understanding of what these how
these different forces are developing
and there this is not a religious
question you know one of the reasons why
this course is a comment is a
collaboration between the school of
management school divinity is precisely
because we recognize this is not just a
religious question it is major social
economic and political consequences so
the question that we then ask arising
out of this is okay so how do we make
how do we make this this world work and
I want to suggest that the following is
essential if we want to make it work
hero five points are made briefly the
first is we need knowledge we need to
have knowledge knowledge is essential
knowledge is good in itself an
explanation knowing being able to
understand the other person this is a
central part of it so one major aspect
of what we've got to do is to make sure
that people have the ability and
capacity an opportunity to learn
ignorance to fear to conflict is one
very obvious train of happenstance
understanding acceptance peace is
another so the fact that you know about
the other person the fact that you
understand where they come from the fact
that you have some concept in your mind
of their cultural background doesn't
mean to say you get on but it it's
obviously help and i would say that
knowledge is essential it's essential at
the at the level of leaders and nations
which is why things like his concept
that turkey in spain launched
about the Alliance of civilizations
which is very much obviously a sort of
counterpoint to the huntington thesis
it's important that that level it is
important to the level of action and I
agree with what daga say and actually
the discussion with Rick about hadn't
the heart to head cake came out of
discussions we we had with Rick and with
others which is that if you start with
action then you're more likely to get
people to interact together without a
lot of complicating theological
questions where you immediately
highlight the differences between people
so for example one part of what we do in
the foundation is to try and get people
to work together on the anti malaria
campaign however and this may seem
strange for me since I come from the
world of the sort of it is supposed to
be the world of practice in politics and
you guys come from the world of academia
I also think though that education not
just in the terms of the exchange of
information but in the academic sense is
an important part of this I think we
need to understand some of the phenomena
that are working here I think we have to
have a far greater ability both in
research empirical evidence and data to
try and work out what are these
different strands that are going on
within the world today and so when I say
my first point is knowledge is essential
I think there's a massive amount that
we've still got to accomplish in in
trying to make that knowledge as deep
and as as deep and as comprehensive as
it as it needs to be the second thing so
that's the first thing how do we make
this world of faith and globalization
work knowledge the second is this you do
need to acknowledge in any society if if
you're going to have a society where
where there's harmony between faiths
there's got to be some common space and
some common rules of engagement and this
is in a sense what we were talking with
Nick last week about you have to accept
the different
base of an equal right to speak you have
to accept that actually the secular
world and the faith world also have
equal rights to speak you have to have
some rules of engagement for this I
think you need as we were saying last
week you need some civility in the
nature of the debate and you also need
countries and societies there are a
different face and different cultures
they've got to have some common space
where people congregate and are prepared
to say this is what we share in common
and this is an important part also of
our identity we don't give up our faith
identity but you know just as in America
when the flag is there people rise to
salute the flag and that is what you do
whatever your faith whatever your color
whatever your background that is a
unifying force actually this is
something that is can be seen as as as
patriotism of course it is but actually
there's something else that's really
important about it it's an indication
that at this point and in this space
everyone comes together and I think
that's a critical part I think it's
critical part of the rules of engagement
for a multi-faith society but I think
you need that comment space and you need
those common rules of engagement I think
thirdly that in practice what this then
means is an attitude that is what i
would call open rather than closed and
that what's more it should be a goal of
public policy to encourage or facilitate
that openness there's an interesting
side consequence of this which is it
actually has an impact on globalization
as well on on your economic policy
because it's very hard to have an a
society that is open in terms of faith
in terms of culture in terms of
background if it's closed economically
so there is a link in fact between the
idea that in the modern world human
capital is
that human capital should be on the
basis of the equal dignity of each human
being and actually a successful economy
where people are recognizing that they
live in a world in which this is going
to be trade between nations exchange of
intellectual human and financial capital
and actually one of the reasons why
protectionism in my view is not a good
response to today's world is partly
because if you take that closed economic
attitude it actually becomes quite hard
to have an open attitude to two people
of different faiths and backgrounds
within society so in practice that
requires an open and not a closed
attitude that should be a goal of Public
Policy and here's one other thing which
i think is really important is that if
you have at that open attitude then I
think it doesn't really work unless it
comes on the basis of that openness
being there available for all and not
simply for a few so there is something
universal about that for it to work now
fourthly even if you believe you have an
exclusive truth faith truth you've still
got to be then supportive of an
inclusive society this is a point the
mirror slappers often often made and i
think it's it's worth just spending a
moment on which is that what he says in
essence that i understand it is is this
that look if you have a faith and lets
you view you're a christian you believe
in salvation through Jesus Christ you
cannot at a certain point I mean that is
that is what you believe is the truth
you cannot at a certain point say well
but I think you who don't believe that
have equal validity because
I mean I obviously that's the the whole
essence of your belief and so miroslav I
think has drawn a distinction between as
it were exclusivity in terms of this is
my my truth my faith truth that I
believe in and then using that as
exclusivity in terms of shutting out the
other person right and I think that is
true but i also think something else
that is interesting about the way
globalization interplays with with with
faith is that as that as that knowledge
deepens and as you learn to inhabit
freely that common space and as that
produces what I would say is a more open
attitude I think faith also evolved in
that process so that so that yes you
still believe in your own faith but your
openness to someone of another faith his
is more than just accepting that they
have that faith and that they believe
it's valid you also start to accept
their spiritual sincerity right even if
you don't necessarily accept their truth
claim and that's quite important and
you're getting some Paul earlier but of
course the extraordinary thing about the
early Christian church was simple going
out and saying this is a message that i
have for greek as well as do that this
is as it were a message that is
universal are not simply restricted to
to to the Jewish people when you come to
islam the whole point about what the
Prophet was saying in a way was to say
you actually have to push it even
broader than the up to then i have the
Jewish faith or the Christian faith had
acknowledged my point is simply
is that the fourth thing I think you
require for and this world of faith and
globalization to work is that at the
least you even if you believe you have
the exclusive truth you've got to want
an inclusive society but I also think
that you need to accept that there is a
level of respect that you have for the
person of a different faith then is more
than simply accepting as a fact that
they have a different faith but you also
accept the sincerity with which they
hold that faith and that and that some
good can come out of it in other words
you know when I engage with somebody of
a different faith who's engaged with us
in our projects for example in Africa on
the anti malaria campaign we work with
with I mean primarily actually with with
Jews and Muslims as well as Christians
hello actually there are Hindus involved
in it as well but when I see what
difference let's say and somebody of the
Jewish faith what difference their faith
mates to them and their actions it's
more than for me simply will I accept
they happen to feel very strongly and
I'm prepared to accept that reality I'm
actually accepting something more than
that I'm accepting that there is a
sincerity about their view and a
motivation as a result of that for them
to do good that sits alongside if you
like the issue to do with who is right
and wrong in a face sense but sits
alongside it quite powerfully you know I
mean so it's it's a this is what I think
is fascinating about the way the world
then developed because yes you keep your
own religious faith and you keep that
strongly but you're very openness to the
other and you're working alongside them
and you're
understanding of why it is that they are
as they are also changes your own sense
of what faith is is is about it doesn't
change your own belief but it does let
you acknowledge somewhat of a different
belief I think at a far more profound
way than simply accepting as a matter of
fact they've got a different faith and
that's where you move I think from
tolerance to respect which is a very
very important part of the journey now
the final thing is is is this and here
is where I think the debate is in the
sense that it at its most interesting
because we've really discussed this very
often for obvious reasons in the context
of what in an era of globalization how
do you make religious faith end up as a
source of coexistence or not and not
that complex so we really am we've
really looked at that the issue of faith
more in terms of of is it a force for
good or ill in faith terms or in social
terms there's something else though that
is is really interesting which is that
globalization is a force but if it is to
be welcomed it needs for the benefits of
that globalization to be shared for the
opportunities not to be restricted and
globalization without values governing
it and underpinning it globalization is
less likely to be accepted less likely
to be successful and actually less
likely to work because if it's not
accepted and it's not successful
globalization itself can become a force
that is that can produce conflict or or
ill and that's why therefore what is
interesting about the role of faith and
why people thought maybe you'd squeeze
faith out of society
as economic prosperity advanced why
isn't it happened in the end it hasn't
happened because of something very deep
within people that says I understand the
benefits of globalization I desire the
material prosperity that may come with
it but I know that in and of itself
there has to be something more in order
to make life worth living right and what
is more that as this globalization which
is in some ways an impersonal force
changes and disrupts people's lives so
there is a desire to reassert some sense
of values some sense of shaping this
process of globalization two ends that
we consider compatible with progress in
humanity so I think the interesting
thing in the end as miroslav was saying
earlier and and Doug was remarking about
the point of which people have religious
faith come to a certain common
understanding the question that faith
does ask about globalization and that
should be asked you don't have to be a
person to faith to ask it incidentally
but it is the question that faith asks
of globalization as to what purpose what
is the end you know what are we trying
to achieve here and without that in my
view globalization is a poorer and
possibly even more dangerous at
phenomenon so that's my view of why this
this matters and what we need to do to
make it to make it work and the
conclusion actually that you come to
overall from this is the relationship
between faith and globalization is
fundamentally important and in order for
it to work the world of faith has got
something to say about this process
not merely from the point of view of how
we avoid conflict between people of
different faiths but actually from the
point of view of how you make this
process of globalization humane and
progressive and working for the benefit
of a volumen kind